ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tengo miedo y me está ayudando las manos
entre otras cosas
pero yo creo que todos los que estamos
aquí todos allá arriba también hemos
sentido que nos suben las manos que se
nos revuelve el estómago que que se nos
va al aire y no podemos ni siquiera
respirar esa sensación de que quieres
que se habla en la tierra y desaparecer
o solamente quieres dormir y dormir y
dormir porque despertar y saber que
tienes una vida y que la tienes que
vivir te llena de pánico
porque el fracaso da miedo no
decepcionar a los que confiaron en ti o
darles la razón a los que te juzgaron
pero el triunfo el triunfo da terror
porque no solamente es llegar es
mantenerte y mientras más alto llegues
más fuerte puede ser la caída y también
te puede dar miedo en la soledad que
tantas veces acompaña el éxito
pero bueno el miedo no siempre es
negativo de hecho es una emoción que nos
sirve como herramienta para protegernos
y no ponernos en peligro gratuitamente
el miedo es uno de los grandes
responsables de la supervivencia de la
especie solamente imagínense si de un
momento a otro eliminaremos todos los
miedos yo creo que esa sería la forma
más eficaz de extinguir a la raza humana
en minutos empezaríamos a caer de todos
lados nos dejaríamos atropellar como
haríamos lo que sea y moriríamos
envenenados habría muchísimos accidentes
imprudenciales ese miedo lo compartimos
con todas las especies y es el famoso
sentido de supervivencia para los que no
me conocen yo soy actriz pero soy actriz
hoy no lo fui siempre de hecho yo empecé
estudiando ingeniería electrónica y al
quinto semestre en la universidad en la
que estaba entro en un paro por
problemas políticos en colombia que casi
no hay
y esto fue como por seis meses y yo
sentí que mi vida se había estancado
entré en pánico y decidí cambiarme de
universidad y me cambié ingeniería
industrial luego busqué un intercambio
para venir a méxico como a los 19 me
regrese a colombia luego busqué otro
intercambio y otro y otro y otro hasta
que me di cuenta que solamente me estaba
siendo pendeja
y que realmente lo que yo quería era
vivir en méxico así que me busque un
cuarto intercambio y me vine
definitivamente a vivir a méxico tomando
una de las decisiones más difíciles que
he tomado en mi vida que fue dejar mi
vida y mi familia en colombia para venir
sola a un país donde no tenía a nadie
más que a mí misma
empezar desde cero
ya viviendo sola tuve mucho tiempo para
empezar a conocerme y me di cuenta que
en algún momento de la vida seguramente
inspirada por alguna telenovela mexicana
porque las vi todas escondidas
me había comprado la idea de que la
única forma de no morir de hambre siendo
mujer era casándome con un millonario o
siendo mucho más chingón a que el
promedio de los hombres para lo que me
tenía que preparar muchísimo pero como
lo del millonario evidentemente no
estaba en mi panorama pues decidí
estudiar una carrera en la que fuera la
segura y por eso lo de la ingeniería
solo qué
aunque me encantaba la ingeniería y
estudiar la trabajar como ingeniera no
era algo que me apasionaba realmente era
algo para lo que había resultado ser
buena y se me daba fácil
y en ese proceso de conocerme me di
cuenta de todas las etiquetas y los
estigmas con los que tenía que vivir
mujer colombiana joven todavía
siempre he viajado mucho no sé por qué
para una mujer es como un delito viajar
sola
y me di cuenta que la única forma de ser
realmente una fregona era haciendo lo
que me apasionaba y deshaciéndome de
todas esas etiquetas que me estorban
para ser quien realmente yo quería hacer
pero la sociedad no me ayudaba la
sociedad nunca ayuda empezaron a atacar
a mis papás con comentarios como es que
las únicas mujeres que viven solas antes
de casarse son las 'iv esta me la
eliminaron a quien no vive necesita vive
sola en mexico
ay qué raro que la niña haya decidido
abandonarlos para exceso la viajar en
que está trabajando
y ahí voy yo de valiente y le agregó una
un punto más a la lista de etiquetas y
me vuelvo actriz
una raya más al tigre
después de un tiempo llegue a estar tan
segura de quién era y de lo que quería
que cualquier etiqueta que me pusieron
se me resbalaba
aprendí a vivir para llenar mi alma no
para quedar bien con nadie
mis papás me vieron tan segura de esa
decisión que a ellos también se les
empezó a resbalar y no solamente me
dejaron ser sino que me apoyaron hemos
disfrutado juntos y hemos sufrido juntos
la libertad de romper paradigmas para
tomar tus propias decisiones
a pesar de tus temores o inseguridades
tiene su precio y a veces es muy alto
pero es un precio que se debe pagar
porque te puedes arriesgar a equivocarte
una y otra yo es más te vas a equivocar
un 5 pero está bien porque quedarte en
la comodidad de la mediocridad nunca se
va a comparar con la maravillosa
sensación de la independencia
y si existen caminos menos arriesgados
como estudiar una carrera que no te deje
morir de hambre o más fácil no estudiar
y buscar quien te mantenga o puedes
tener hijos a temprana edad y así
asegurar un futuro que ojo yo no estoy
diciendo que ser padre o madre no sea
una maravillosa forma de sentirte
realizado como ser humano pero sí estoy
segura que no es la única
es más puede ser que no quieras tener
hijos y eso está bien está muy bien está
perfecto es parte del control de
natalidad ya somos un chingo
pero no te puedes pero si lo haces
porque así debe ser por miedo y no por
ser feliz no vale lo mismo porque no te
puedes quedar en una vida en la que no
eres feliz solamente porque te sientes
cómodo o seguro o porque te dejas frenar
por el pánico a vivir porque nada puede
salir mal
es como ir al parque de diversiones y
solamente subirte al carrusel
si te subas a la montaña rusa puede ser
que lo recuerdes toda la vida ya sea
porque te la pasa está increíble o por
qué saliste con collarín pero cualquiera
de los dos panoramas va a ser un gran
aprendizaje prohibido que te paraliza el
que bloquea tus sueños es el que está
ligado a la resistencia al cambio pero
ese miedo es imaginario existencialista
muy difícil de vencer porque lo
desconocido es incierto es impredecible
y asusta pero si quieres crecer no te
queda más remedio que enfrentarlo cada
vez que aparezca y aventarte
obviamente hay que hacerlo con cuidado
porque yo aprendí a golpes que hacer lo
que te hace feliz no significa actuar es
lo mismo
y sin medir las consecuencias de
analizar los recursos con los que
cuentas significa sentarte y pensar bien
escribir si es necesario porque es lo
mejor para ti porque si te hace feliz te
enriquece y te hace bien entonces es lo
mejor para ti al final de la historia no
te quedas con las decisiones seguras de
esas probablemente ni te acuerdes al
final de la historia te quedas con los
momentos más chingones
cuando yo tenía cuatro años me dio
meningitis
aparentemente los únicos las únicas
secuelas fue una reducción en la
audición y un pequeño retraso en mi
desarrollo motriz mi desarrollo
cognitivo no se vio afectado eso me
hicieron creer toda la vida
cuando tenía 11 mi maestro de educación
física me gritó en frente de todo el
salón es que eres esa motriz y yo que
era una adolescente bastante
insoportable me creía todo lo que me
decían sobre todo lo malo
y muchos años después voy de valía otra
vez a estudiar actuación sin tener en
cuenta que la herramienta principal del
actor es su cuerpo un actor no puede
hacer home office un actor es 100%
presencial vas y te paras en el set o en
el escenario y representas el personaje
que tienes que interpretar para contar
una historia y el primer año de carrera
teníamos que hacer una obra corporal en
la que todos teníamos que bailar y los
que cantaban cantaban y con eso se
contaba una historia yo entré en pánico
yo soy a motriz yo no puedo bailar no me
puedo parar en un escenario a bailar
frente a muchísimas personas y empecé se
empezó a revolucionar mi cabeza con toda
mi creatividad a buscar la mejor de las
excusas me hice operar la rodilla
derecha
y no hice la obra por supuesto que mi
rodilla podía esperar mucho para
operarse es más si me cuidaba no me la
iba a tener que parar nunca pero para
que me aventaja si tenía tanto miedo
pase desapercibida y no lo hice triunfe
lo que yo no conté es que la vida no se
terminaba ahí y que al año siguiente iba
a haber otro corporal y yo ya no tenía
nada que operarme
no tenía ninguna excusa y lo tuve que
hacer
no fui la estrella yo pero no me caí no
me rompí nada y lo más importante es que
me di cuenta que no soy ya motriz y que
puedo como actriz interpretar muchísimos
personajes entrenando mi cuerpo
adecuadamente
hoy las mujeres tenemos bien
y esta es la parte más que más me cuesta
trabajo decir hoy las mujeres tenemos
miedo pero es un miedo diferente
porque ese miedo que me ha paralizado
tantas veces para subirme a un escenario
ese miedo puede ser emocionante y hasta
retador
pero el miedo que sentimos todos los
días el miedo a ser asesinadas violadas
ultrajadas o simplemente a ser
rechazadas por el hecho de haber nacido
mujeres con su miedo nos acompaña a
todas partes
y es terrible temer a los hombres y que
ese temor que se generalice
porque por lo menos en mi caso gran
parte de quien soy hoy y la fuerza que
tuvo para sacarme adelante se lo debo a
mi mamá
pero el amor en la vida la búsqueda
incansable de la libertad y la confianza
en mí porque es todo toda mi vida me
dijo tú puedes tú puedes tú puedes se lo
digo a mi papá
ese ser que con su gran amor
me hizo creer en mí
él es mi superhéroe y yo para él soy
perfecta
entonces yo les pregunto cómo funciona
la ecuación
ocho de cada diez mujeres en méjico
hemos sido víctimas de violencia física
o sexual
el 75% propiciada por hombres cercanos a
nosotros
y nueve mujeres aproximadamente mueren
al día en mexico asesinadas por hombres
entonces les pregunto es suficiente con
querer seguir tus sueños aventarte
enfrentar tus miedos sí sin duda es una
gran herramienta y sin duda es de gran
ayuda pero desafortunadamente nuestra
condición de mujeres lo hace mucho más
difícil
y hoy quiero exhortar a todas las
mujeres
a no quedarse calladas por miedo no
estamos solas
a no tirarse a no tirarnos entre
nosotras a cuidarnos entre nosotras ya
no fomentar las conductas machistas eso
es muy importante y a los hombres a
valorar a todas las mujeres por igual
señoras no solamente sus santas madres
son dignas de respeto todas las mujeres
tenemos exactamente los mismos derechos
que ustedes y tenemos el derecho a vivir
en un mundo seguro y que esa seguridad
no se vea comprometida únicamente por
haber nacido mujeres y a todos hombres y
mujeres a levantar un espejo en frente
de nosotros identificar y erradicar
todas esas violencias que ejercemos en
otros
o escuchar para relajarnos un poquito
los voy a dejar con una historia de amor
que se detuvo por miedo hace 40 años mi
papá conoció el amor de su vida en
bélgica
y a él le quitaron la visa y lo sacaron
del país
mónica le ofreció ayuda para para que se
quedara para ayudarlo a conseguir
trabajo y le dijo que a sí mismos
y él se subió en su orgullo y dijo yo
soy el hombre a mí no me tienes que
ayudar yo me voy que me voy contigo se
fue a visitarlo colombia él se regresó a
colombia se fue a visitarlo muchas veces
hasta que estalló la guerra contra el
narcotráfico y como ya se extranjera y
güerita pues creían que era gringa
entonces que correr mucho peligro
y hace como tres años
yo estaba aquí con mi papá en mexico
yo crecí con las historias de mónica mis
papás se separaron cuando yo tenía un
año que bueno que no se quedaron juntos
porque si no yo no estaría aquí
contándoles esta historia
pero hace como tres años estábamos aquí
en méxico y en una de las historias mi
papá me contó
yo la fui a acompañar al aeropuerto la
última vez que nos vimos nos despedimos
los dos sabiendo que era la última vez
pero ninguno de los dos dijo nada yo oí
cómo se llenaba el avión se empezó a
mover despegó y cuando se
desapareció en una nube negra yo sentí
que me arrancaron el corazón esto lo
dijo mi papá sus 70 años con lágrimas
que no podía frenar
yo en ese momento elegí fijaron la voy a
encontrar él se enojó muchísimo
olvídate no te metas en esto nuestro
rollo y me lo prohibió a mí me valió
obviamente la busqué durante un año
hasta que la encontré y ella me contestó
diciéndome que también había sido el
amor de su vida y que por supuesto que
le encantaría vernos
y fuimos a verla bueno antes de eso le
hablé a mi papá para contarle y él se
quedó callado un muy buen rato y asia
un pánico de que no me volviera a hablar
se empezó a morir de risa y me dijo por
eso te amo tanto porque si no te da
miedo vivir y tú siempre luchas por lo
que quieres y ahí les van a sorpresa
aquí se conocieron en egipto hace 40
años
esta fue la foto que mónica guardo toda
su vida en la sala de su casa
este fue el encuentro con mi mochila de
flores
nos quedamos una semana los tres juntos
y yo en paparazzi todo el tiempo
[Música]
esta ya fue en su casa en bruselas
esto nada más lo metí porque me encantó
saludos en bici en el campo divino super
viernes
y esta fue la despedida que fue tan o
más emotiva que el encuentro
y se me pone bien chido
yo todos los días tengo miedo
me da no ser capaz me da no ser
suficiente miedo a mí misma porque
nosotros somos nuestros peores enemigos
muchas veces miedo a muchas cosas
incluso meses a cosas absurdas pero hoy
les puedo decir con más seguridad que
nunca que el miedo hace parte de la
naturaleza humana te puede destruir si
tú lo permites o puedes decidir darle la
vuelta y convertirlo en tu motor
pero mis ganas de vivir son más fuertes
a mí ya no me da miedo vivir gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]